For the reserve parachute we ultimately use very simple lines, mostly also Dyneema, which are however rather thick and also woven much, much less densely.
Because exactly there it's important, as already mentioned before, that if we have an opening, there isn't a huge load, rather the whole system is allowed to stretch.
It's absolutely secondary that it's form-stable, dimensionally stable lengthwise — that it's allowed to stretch and does stretch actually has these positive properties.
With the reserve parachute there are quite different models. Here we quickly see the one in the middle, that's a so-called cross-cell canopy.
That's pretty much what's currently on the market and works very well.
Then bottom left, the red one, is rather an older model, that's a round canopy, which is currently being displaced a bit by the cross-cell canopy, for one simple reason, because the cross-cell canopy is very pendulum-stable.
And with the round canopy we tend to have a pendulum in it.
And then there are also various other shapes — this one here is a triangle, where you can pick up some forward speed and with which you can steer.
However, that's reserved more for pros, because after the deployment you also have to actively steer the reserve parachute.
For a student, for someone who's starting to fly, it absolutely makes sense to have a cross-cell canopy — with that you come down and everything's fine and you don't have to focus on a reserve system too.
When you pull a reserve parachute, a reserve system, you come down at about 5.5 metres per second, that corresponds approximately, as we see here in the picture, to a height of 1.5 metres.
But for a 1.5-metre jump we don't have nothing on, rather we have the whole paragliding equipment, the harness, also our clothes, helmet etc. on, that means it's quickly a lot of weight and then the 1.5 metres may suddenly be rather difficult or also with a small impact.
In reality it actually looks like we jump from rather 2 to 3 metres, because reserve parachutes are tested by being deployed from a helicopter or from a bridge, but always without a paraglider.
So that is, there's a weight attached, it's deployed, it falls down, that's it.
In reality we usually still have the paraglider connected to us and the paraglider can also interfere a bit.
That means, the whole system tends to swing a bit and definitely influences the sink rate and it can then also quickly be a bit higher.
However, it's really built so that if you come down on your feet, it's actually an impact you can absorb well.
Most importantly, that you really come down on your feet and don't somehow have the feeling, you'd sit down and come onto the protector of the harness.
The protector is never as good as our legs.
A better protector is our leg.
Therefore the absolute priority after a reserve toss must be to land on your feet.
Speaking of protectors, there are very different harnesses that have protectors.
And on the left side we now have one that has a foam built in.
That of course has the advantage, the protection is there from the start.
It just has the big disadvantage, it's relatively heavy and especially the volume, when you pack it, is quite large.
There are other forms.
There we said, we want to have the volume relatively small and made airbags,
which however only fill once we're in the air, when the airflow blows into them.
And at launch, where it was actually very important with the protection, we have no protection.
There are also sub-forms, where for example a harness can be made directly into a backpack.
That's called a convertible harness.
The convertible harness of course has the advantage that you don't need an extra backpack, so weight savings.
But we make the material relatively light.
We stress the material relatively hard.
And we also open and close the zippers very often.
That means, there tends to be more damage.
And the protector may be packed in such a way that it's relatively compressed in there and deflates.
Afterwards it doesn't unfold as nicely after multiple uses.
To solve the whole thing a bit, one manufacturer has developed a very good system,
which you can see here in the right-hand image.
He has developed a harness which you inflate.
Already before launch.
So by hand or with such an inflation bag.
So that the air is inside.
You close it up and already from launch have a super protector.
And if you don't need it, you let the air out.
You have a very low volume and very little weight with you.
There's of course also the extreme form, that people choose for example for hike-and-fly.
They say they completely forgo protection.
We see that in the top left corner.
Where there's really only the basic.
So a strap.
In which you sit comfortably.
That has no protection.
And you have to attach the reserve parachute separately too.
You can't integrate it into a harness.
Another form is the prone harness.
There's now also a huge market from light to heavy.
Ultimately the big advantage of the prone harness is quite clearly,
that you of course lie aerodynamically in the air.
That's better glide performance of the wing.
And you're relatively well shielded from the wind.
So you stay warm if you're doing long flights.
You have relatively a lot of room for a cockpit.
You see up there.
There's even a light little shelf in front.
Where you can of course also optimally place devices.
And have a good view of the devices.
Anyone who flies a bit of competitions.
Or does long cross-country flights.
Is several hours in the air.
Actually picks a prone harness.
Because it definitely has these advantages.
The disadvantages are that you're a bit awkward to climb into.
Because you don't sit fully upright.
That's a completely different feeling.
You have to learn it.
And you don't have a direct view upward.
Therefore in school it absolutely makes sense
to choose a sitting harness.
And then there are, as explained, various classes.
There are hike-and-fly harnesses.
There are XC harnesses.
The acro pilots, freestyle pilots
again have a different harness.
There are very different and good harnesses on the market.
Get advice there too.
It's worth sitting in them.
And finding out which harness fits you.
The construction of the paraglider is ultimately
very simple.
It's about having a riser.
We also see that here,
where we're ultimately attached.
Then the brake handles,
where we ultimately are in.
Here a small note.
If you have the brake handles,
hold them like this.
Wrap them once like this.
But never put your hand through and fly like this.
Because if you were inside the brake handle like that
and you had to pull the reserve parachute,
it can be, especially in winter,
when we still have gloves on,
that we'd struggle as if shackled to get out.
So develop a technique
with which you can cleanly bring out your hand at any time.
Then we have the line,
namely the brake line, which is at the very back
attached to the trailing edge of the wing.
And after that come C, B and A riser groups.
A riser group is the foremost,
where you can ultimately use the wing
to pull up at launch.
Then up to the sail we go to the trailing edge,
which is called the trailing edge.
At the front is the leading edge or leading edge,
where the air enters.
And then we have the upper and lower sail.
And inside the paraglider we also have a lot of internal structure.
There we have cells, partition walls
and we have the so-called crossports.
Crossports are nothing other than holes
in the cell wall, which ensure
that the air can distribute evenly in the wing.
As we've already seen with a paraglider,
you see that it has openings at the front
and toward the stabilo, toward the edge of the paraglider,
the openings are often closed.
And so that the air can get in there too,
which causes the pressure
that the wing lies super nicely in the air
and is open, we make the crossports,
then air equalisation takes place
and the whole wing looks beautifully filled in the air.
The risers themselves we've seen before.
These are the line levels.
We have line links,
which are small screw-link carabiners
and we have the accelerator.
Here we see a foot accelerator,
where with the foot, that is, you first clip in,
connect with the harness
and can press with the foot.
Nothing other happens,
than that here the A riser group is pulled up.
Through which, what happens,
the angle of attack becomes smaller,
the wing becomes faster.
The foot accelerator, as you see here in the picture,
is mostly built into solo wings,
because there the pilots can stretch wonderfully with their leg
and cleanly influence the speed on their wing.
Where it works less well is with the tandem wing.
On the tandem wing we have trimmers,
as we see here,
which you can let backwards,
as discussed.
And that you can of course do wonderfully by hand
and don't need your foot,
because in front there's the passenger and you have no space at all.
The advantage of the trimmer is of course,
if you can adjust it by hand,
you can also see it nicely.
The disadvantage is,
you can't simply release it quickly again.
There you have to actively reach up with your hand.
With the foot accelerator you can press and let go,
it goes back by itself,
is somewhat easier to operate.
Trimmer, trimming, not to be confused,
here we then talk about the line,
which you can trim.
Now we heard earlier with the line materials,
that here we have various lines,
which partly shrink a bit,
stretch a bit
and the manufacturer tries
to prevent this as much as possible,
by making a good mix of the respective lines.
It still happens
that the line deforms,
respectively gets longer or somewhat shorter
and you measure that in the check.
And now you discover
that the lines have indeed lengthened somewhat.
Then you can for example put a tube in
and trim the wing by 1–2 cm,
so that it flies again like new.
That's done with a measuring procedure in the paraglider check
and so you can very precisely find out,
where is the line set a bit warped,
where can I correct something,
so that it flies cleanly again.
So, the wing you can also kind of re-trim,
and bring back to an almost new state,
when it's been used a bit more heavily.
What applies to the whole material,
regardless of wing,
harness,
or line,
ultimately we want to have fun with it for a long time.
That's why it's important
that we also know
what actually damages the material.
Basically you can say
that mechanical load is certainly a load
that should be avoided.
So I don't drag the material along the ground,
ultimately friction is simply bad for all material.
And by mechanical load it's meant,
if you fly strong manoeuvres,
so where the wing is strongly stressed,
with a lot of G-load,
then the wing will certainly also age faster,
than if you don't do that.
UV radiation plays a big role,
when we're of course in the air,
we can't avoid it.
Where you can avoid it though,
is when we have the material on the ground,
that we pack it up
and put it in the shade,
so that the UV radiation...
UV radiation is something
you can't entirely avoid,
because in the air of course it's the case
that it's exposed to the sun.
Where you could avoid it though,
is on the ground,
when we've landed,
pack the wing,
put it in the shade,
so that as little sun as possible shines on it
and so the UV hours can be reduced as much as possible
and it's only exposed in the air.
Moisture is generally a topic.
On the one hand for the line it's not good,
because it starts to shrink,
if they're really wet,
especially very wet.
And the wing being wet isn't a problem,
if you also dry it right away.
It's bad,
if a paraglider is wet
and you then pack it in a stuff sack
and you don't touch this sack for 2–3 weeks,
then that's certainly not the best for the material.
Absolutely to avoid,
if you have a wet wing,
then dry it,
spread it out at home
and only pack it back when dry.
The very worst thing
we can do
is, if we have a wet wing
and then expose it to temperatures,
with temperature the classic example is in the car.
In summer it quickly goes over 30–40 degrees in the car
and then in there we really have a bit of an oven
and the whole thing affects the material very, very badly.
So check,
whether your material is dry
and that it's not exposed to extreme temperatures.
Acid is something —
perhaps you've once picked up a landing-field souvenir,
namely a cow pat —
is ultimately also something
that attacks the wing or rather the coating,
but what's also important,
is that you do clean it,
with lukewarm water,
but not somehow with cleaning agents,
because those attack the coating.
And speaking of coating,
good keyword,
the paraglider has a coating on it,
so that it doesn't react too strongly to UV rays
and that it especially doesn't let too much air through.
This porosity,
because if a wing lets too much air through,
it loses performance,
loses speed
and you want to prevent,
with this coating,
that this happens.
The coating,
which you see here,
the ripstop weave,
is of course of varying thickness,
because the thread is of varying thickness
and the coating is packed on top
and on top it's actually ensured,
that the differences of the thick threads
are evened out,
that it thus becomes a uniform cloth,
that it becomes UV-resistant,
that the air permeability is good
and generally to mechanical load
reacts less quickly.
I hope
this materials talk pleased you,
moves you forward in learning
and that you ace the materials subject
and simply pass it at the briefing.